and finally new rule while this thing of
defeat is still fresh and the horrors
resulting from that defeat pile up
liberals must examine all the reasons
why we keep losing elections starting
with Democrats have gone from the party
that protects people to the party that
protects feelings from ask not what your
country can do for you
- you owe me an apology Republicans
apologize for nothing Democrats for
everything can't we find a balance you
know in 2016 conservatives won the White
House both houses of Congress and almost
two-thirds of governorships and state
legislatures whereas liberals on the
other hand caught Steve Martin calling
Carrie Fisher beautiful in a tweet and
made him take it down I'm not making
that up that really happened
here's Steve's offensive tweet when I
was a young man Carrie Fisher was the
most beautiful creature I'd ever seen
she turned out to be witty and bright as
well
how could you Steve we thought we knew
you but this you noted her appearance
first and then that she was witty and
bright you're a monster
liberals do this all the time they get
offended for people who themselves would
not be offended you know that whole
controversy about the name Washington
Redskins they did a survey nine out of
ten actual Indians don't give a [ __ ]
why would way they're in their ancestors
learn firsthand that New England
Patriots G
[Applause]
what that definitely stopped celebrities
from groveling when they get caught
playing dress up on Halloween
here's Hilary Duff last year and then of
course her tweet I'm so sorry two people
I offended it was not properly thought
through it I am truly from the bottom of
my heart sorry Chris Hemsworth was even
more beside himself with self-loathing
after he attended a Lone Ranger themed
party dressed as an Indian he wrote I
was stupidly unaware of the offense I
sincerely and unreservedly apologized to
all First Nations people for this
thoughtless action I hope that is
highlighting my own ignorance I could
help in some small well for [ __ ] sake
your Thor role affair you didn't offend
Indians any more than you have been gays
would you wear a cape and Hammer guy it
was a lone ranger themed party you could
only be a cowboy Indian or a horse just
like at the 11 Wyoming last year Justin
Timberlake tweeted that an
african-american Jesse Williams inspired
him and again had to apologize for the
sin of giving some of the compliment I
apologize to anyone that felt that we
got a third I have nothing but love for
all of you at all of us oh good good
because life knows no sin greater than
the one he was accused of doing which
was cultural appropriation cultural
appropriation that's the idea that white
people shouldn't adopt things from other
ethnic groups how dare you mix and match
cultures to produce something new where
do you think you are some kind of
melting pot
you know the majority of Americans are
actually with the Democrats on the
issues raising minimum wage sensible gun
laws path to citizenship abortion rights
pro-environment
you name it but we keep losing now
there's a lot of reasons for that but
the one we can immediately fix is the
too often Democrats remind people of a
man who has taken his balls out and put
them in his wife's purse
and please someone tweet me right now
and tell me how that was somehow
inappropriate so I can tell you to go
[ __ ] yourself
[Applause]
at the Golden Globes this month Michael
Keaton mixed up the titles of two movies
that had a black cast hidden figures and
fences and said hidden fences because
he's a Klansman he was the outrage cue
the retraction I screwed up it makes me
feel so badly that people feel badly if
someone feels badly that's all that
matters
no that's not all that matters in fact
things like this don't matter at all
what matters is that while you
self-involved fools were policing the
language at the Kids Choice Awards a
madman talked his way into the White
House
what matters is that while liberals are
in a contest to see who could be the
first to call out fat shaming the Tea
Party has been busy taking over school
boards stop protecting your virgin ears
and start noticing your getting [ __ ]
in the ass okay